plus les semaines passent plus c'est
dangereux de sortir dans la rue pour
exiger le départ du président alexandre
loukachenko
mais samedi elle était quand même des
mille la grande marche des femmes encore
tourné au chaos
si la triste coutume il prix à payer dit
celle qui a inspiré une mobilisation
populaire sans précédent dans l'histoire
du pays mais le camp tu nous as one of
freedom and sky a quitté le bélarus le
soir des élections qu'elle soutient
avoir remporté elle nous a parlé de
vilnius en lituanie où elle a dû
s'exiler pour protéger surtout ses
enfants qui ont 5 et 10 ans kidman
ils ont peut être un papier dans un
sketch ouailles il ya sept ans attirent
dans ce cas candidate résider à dire
qu'il ya deux mois svetlana à tirano sky
a était presque inconnu
bien qu'elle n'ait aucune expérience en
politique elle se porte candidate à la
présidence lorsque son mari un blogueur
et candidat potentiel est arrêté est en
prison elle dit l'avoir fait par amour
elle devient rapidement un phénomène
d'un bout à l'autre du pays
mais elle est aujourd'hui la seule des
trois femmes qui étaient offrant à ne
pas avoir été arrêtée leader
accidentelle de son propre aveu n'a
d'ailleurs aucune intention de
solliciter la présidence advenant de
nouvelles élections et c'est pour ça les
suivantes cette femme parce qu'elle
n'aspire pas au contrôle et au pouvoir
elle se bat pour nous un rôle que ce
mec-là nature à neuf ce qu'aia
apprivoise avec le soutien de la
communauté internationale y compris
l'aide du ministre canadien des affaires
étrangères
elle en est à préparer une liste de
sanctions quelle somme l'europe
d'adopter pour punir un régime qui n'a
plus que la violence et le soutien de la
russie pour se maintenir au pouvoir
hao a provoqué le bélarus dit elle et on
l'a croisée des chemins entre la
dictature et la liberté
ils sont à marc altéré scorel de canada
moscou